comment vendre
vibromasseur là c'est pas cette chanson
là qui se branche sur l'allume-cigare
quel argument vous vous développeriez
pour le vendre mais c'est très pratique
bonsoir
bon bah oui moi je suis allé donc vous
voir sur scène Patrick début mai on
s'est pas revu depuis je voulais pas
trop la jouer animateur de télé mais
enfin c'était vachement bien j'ai passé
une très bonne soirée d'abord parce
qu'il y avait ça
[Musique]
casser la foi ensuite il y avait ça
une mise en scène tous les mots qui me
viennent sont dérisoires
c'est bien je l'ai trop dit
quand même et ça regarde
un peu
je vais pas me taire parce que nos yeux
il y avait ça
ah bah quand même
[Musique]
si je te disais que j'ai pas voulu il y
avait ça pour la vie
pour la
vie nous change qui dérange toutes les
idées sur tout voilà donc au départ déjà
il y avait de bonnes chansons ensuite
il y a un moment où je trouve très
rigolo vous mettez une petite casquette
de titi parisien et puis vous chantez
déjà ça j'ai trouvé ça très très drôle
c'était une manière de passer d'une
chanson qui s'appelle Ellie qui est
consacrée à mon grand-père
derrière laquelle il est assez difficile
de mettre quelque chose et je suis passé
par une autre émotion celle de la menthe
Saint-Jean pour aller vers quelque chose
d'un peu plus d'un peu plus ludique je
me suis amusé avec un accordéon avec mes
musiciens qui ont mis des casquettes
puis on a fait un petit côté un petit
côté
mon amant de Saint-Jean la romance de
Paris vous allez finir comme Yves
Montand
une version inattendue de votre première
chanson votre premier tube c'est pas
votre première chanson vous vous parlez
de pétard c'est très rigolo
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous
ou bien
au début c'était la vraie version
originale
c'est réservé aux gens qui vont concert
maintenant c'est pour les gens qui vont
concerne ils ont en plus la fin de la
chanson se termine avec une petite
surprise qui se passe à l'Opéra alors il
y a un CD vous sortez un CD là
[Musique]
à la maison mais j'ai peur d'avoir l'air
con si je fais ça à la télé c'est quoi
ça c'est bien ça c'est comme ça c'est
nous quand on fait de la pub déjà on dit
qu'on fait de la pub voilà
ça fait con quand même non
non
toi tout seul au milieu et les autres
ils font pas ça fait bizarre
personne le fait sauf que ma fille
[Applaudissements]
bon alors ça c'est des s'appelle juste
avant
le premier single c'était je te
mentirais le deuxième single c'est pour
la vie et le troisième single c'est ça
[Musique]
qui s'appelle Marie Florence gros qui
est maire de famille qui a 35 ans qui a
fait HEC qui est docteur esletre et qui
a bossé avec vous alors j'aime bien
savoir comment vous l'avez rencontré
par un j'allais dire par hasard en fait
non on sait un jour Louis Michel Colas
directeur de la Gaîté Montparnasse qui
est un garçon adorable et qui a mais qui
est très très persuasif qui a pris son
téléphone qui m'a appelé qui m'a dit tu
dois rencontrer deux jeunes qui écrivent
des chansons
ils vont écrire une chanson je dis ouais
super envoyez-moi une cassette ah non
non ils viennent chez toi avec une
guitare il chante des chansons je dis
ouais bien sûr j'ai que ça à [ __ ] et
ils m'ont dit il faut absolument qu'il
rappelle qu'il insiste je dis attends
mais je vais pas recevoir tous les gens
qui ont envie de me chanter des chansons
sinon je fais plus que ça il m'a dit non
non mais tu as beaucoup tu as une
demi-heure à perdre beaucoup à gagner il
a tellement insisté il était midi moins
20 je lui ai dit écoute d'accord mais à
midi là parce que sinon on pourra pas
ils sont pointés avec une guitare et
puis ils vont chanter une chanson
c'est une rencontre d'une nuit à
raconter un petit peu comment ça s'est
passé quand même parce que en plus c'est
autobiographique mais je le raconte sur
scène tous les soirs
franchement alors là une chanson alors
là on change ensemble c'est la meuf qui
m'a pécho c'est ça qui est difficile
elle me regarde dans les yeux elle
m'attrape elle me fait me promener dans
la dans les dans les rues de Caracas
elle m'emmène dans un hôtel elle me fait
comme tu dis mon affaire au matin elle
s'est tirée je pense qu'elle m'a tout
piquée en fait elle m'a rien piqué du
tout elle s'est barrée à la même payé la
chambre c'est beau
et ensuite et ensuite et ensuite
et ensuite évidemment je
me dis comment je fais pour la laisser
partir et je ne l'ai jamais revu
justement pas c'est une histoire vraie
mais justement pas tu veux il faut que
tu il faut que tu laisses cette part de
romantisme ce qu'il y en a une heure
c'est le garçon qui fonctionne
alors l'album en question donc quel est
qui s'appelle juste avant il en est à
quoi 700 000 exemplaires 800 pour un
retour c'est bien 900 maintenant
Patrick avec le café des délices et Elie
vous renouez avec vos avec vos origines
d'une certaine façon je crois que c'est
la première fois que vous chantez des
chansons qui qui concernent vos origines
alors vous êtes né à Clem scène votre
mère était institutrice vous avez un an
lorsque votre père quitte le domicile
conjugal en 1960 en 62 l'été 62 c'est le
retour en France et finalement vous
dites comme on avait rien on a rien eu à
abandonner d'une certaine façon parce
que votre grand-père était secrétaire de
mairie à Tlemcen et finalement ça vous a
pas tellement coûté de partir
apparemment non attention à l'âge de 3
ans ça coûte pas
la plupart était né dans laquelle ils
ont vécu c'est le déracinement l'arrivée
en métropole je crois que ça a pas été
facile pour pour beaucoup de gens il y a
des gens qui ont laissé des biens très
importants il y a des gens qui n'ont
laissé qui ont laissé autre chose qui
ont laissé effectivement donc vous
installez avec votre mère Argentil
alors le départ de votre père et puis
finalement le fait de vous retrouver
tous les deux comme ça Argenteuil ça
vous rapproche encore d'elle d'une
certaine façon alors c'est peut-être la
psychanalyse de bistrot mais est-ce que
c'est pour ça qu'à 40 ans vous êtes
toujours tout seul vous cherchez encore
la femme de votre vie donc qu'est-ce qui
vous dit que je suis tout seul
c'est pas marié ah parce que si on est
pas marié on est tout seul on vous
connaît pas d'aventure durable
peut-être que ma discrétion
vous auriez trouvé quelqu'un de mieux
que votre mère non mais ça c'est la
psychanalyse même pas de comptoir ça
c'est avant le comptoir
non pourquoi non sérieux blague à part
vous avez eu peur que votre couple
finisse comme celui de vos parents donc
j'ai pas eu peur il est
probable parce que vous voulez faire de
la psychanalyse qui a certains schémas
non là on est on va monter un peu plus
haut il y a des schémas qu'on a
peut-être pas envie de reproduire c'est
sûr donc il y a une peur qui peut
s'installer mais enfin mais c'est pas
totalement c'est pas lié uniquement la
peur non non
à des rencontres et à une évidence on
rencontre quelqu'un une évidence si on
n'a pas cette évidence on attend et puis
c'est vrai qu'avec la vie la vie qu'on
mène et les et les sollicitations et
c'est énorme on n'est pas on voyage
beaucoup on bouge beaucoup on est en
mouvement
et vous avez pas passé le sentiment
d'être passé à côté de quelqu'un
quelqu'un vous dites maintenant avec le
recul finalement elle j'aurais peut-être
dû non
non la première peut-être
la brésilienne
à New York en 79 oui bah aujourd'hui
j'aurais peut-être un j'aurais voilà
j'aurais peut-être un enfant aujourd'hui
qui serait avançant de l'équipe du
Brésil etc
en tous les cas vous avez rencontré
presque alors à New York et il cherchait
un piano et vous aviez une copine qui
avait un piano
alors elle avait oui sa mère c'est pour
ça qu'elle voulait un fils un beau fils
riche et plein de de je sais pas vous
voulez quelque chose d'autre aussi pour
sa fille vous avez dit c'est vrai
alors vous avez des vous dites vous êtes
fort dans la séduction mais après ça
dure pas très longtemps j'ai dit notre
tragédie je suis facile à séduire je
suis pas facile à garder c'est ça
maintenant c'est réglé
ça a l'air d'être bien parti là
[Musique]
je vous demande de vous arrêter
[Rires]
on va revenir au 10 donc c'est un énorme
succès comme on vient de le dire
maintenant quand vous repensez à la
Bruelle Mania vous y pensez comment pour
vous c'est douloureux ou c'est
non c'est à dire que
c'est difficile à cerner cette histoire
parce que entre le entre la relation
médiatique il y a eu avec avec ça et ce
qui s'est passé fondamentalement avec le
public il y a toujours eu un décalage la
description faite par les médias
esquissent que je vivais dans les salles
étaient décalé c'est à dire que les
médias parlaient d'hystéry moi je voyais
de l'enthousiasme je voyais de la
ferveur
c'était très toute venait très
réducteurs
les gens étaient assez Patrick pendant
des heures le Patrick avec 5 I qui me
Riss et qui me rend fou et qui qui est
terrifiant ça je l'ai pas dans les
salles je l'ai parlé les gens qui me
chambre un peu
elles ont pris 10 ans aussi donc oui
mais il y en a des nouvelles qui ont 15
ans il y a beaucoup de gens
étonnant c'est vrai que la majorité des
des des des composent le public ont
entre 25 et 30 ans par exemple un
épisode comme là la Pizza Pino vous
étiez là vous pouviez plus sortir vous
êtes passés chez un
coiffeurs
par exemple c'est des souvenirs
douloureux pour vous mais non sur le
moment mais ce qui est douloureux c'est
toute la récupération qu'il y en a eu
qui qui a été faite et tout ce qui a été
dit derrière nous on est tout simplement
avec Arcadi à 6h du soir parce qu'il a
ses bureaux à côté qu'on doit écouter
une chanson et finalement il me dit
tiens on va boire un coup dans cette
pizzeria où on a passé notre vie on est
tout le temps là on était tout le temps
là-bas euh on était à 6h du soir au fond
du truc on n'a jamais été en terrasse
qui rentrait qui m'a vu qui a appelé des
copines ça fait un espèce de mouvement
nous on s'est marré et puis ensuite on a
essayé de se barrer mais là c'était
difficile et ensuite il y a eu presque
machin Tintin il y a des gens qui ont
dit qu'on avait monté le truc
mais c'est vrai qu'à un moment le la
dimension sociologique de votre carrière
a remporté sur dimension artistique
quand même non et ben je suis heureux de
vous l'entendre dire non mais c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai bien sûr quelqu'un a été
utilisé a été étudié par des
psychanalystes
que je salue ici alors eux ils disent
que eux ils voient dans la rue Allemagne
dimension sexuelle très sérieusement ils
disent que ça permet aux adolescentes de
s'abriter d'une sexualité trop précoce
c'est une manière pour elle d'attendre
et de tenir le coup la brouellemania
c'était ça pour eux ça vous fait marrer
l'amour que les fans vous portent
que des fans peuvent porter à des
artistes en général c'est vous c'était
particulièrement c'est le cas pour voilà
et donc si vous étiez en fait comme un
paratonnerre c'est-à-dire qu'elle se
reportée sur vous
j'adore me sentir utile si tu es
vachement utile
alors il y a un sociologue lui qui
s'appelle
Patrick migon après il y a le
proctologue
tout le monde a bossé sur le coup
le sociologue Patrick Migaud il a dit il
faut que Patrick Bruel se marie pour
négocier habilement sa reconversion et
ce que je remarque c'est que vous avez
réussi votre conversion sans vous marier
finalement comme quoi aujourd'hui mais
quoi exactement ça
c'est difficile à décrire parce que ce
qui se passe dans les salles en ce
moment-là
vous n'êtes pas venu à Lille
venez voir un peu c'est assez incroyable
mais à la fois j'ai pas l'impression que
ce soit tellement différent mais c'est
la description en effet qui est
différente et c'est là et c'est le
regard sur le faut demander à des gens
il y en a plein ici qui sont en concert
qui sont des petites la musique
Caracas sur son visage
Christine et ça se passe comment alors
est-ce qu'il y a la même hystérie qui a
10 ans
et
une soirée entre amis et puis il y a une
ambiance formidable
il y a jamais eu d'hystérie il y a
quelques hystérique qui font boule de
neige mais franchement il y a jamais eu
d'hystérique les vrais fans ne sont pas
hystériques et voilà merci beaucoup
les vrais fans ne sont pas hystériques
bon oui alors Patrick Bruel à une époque
donc à la grande époque de cette Bruelle
manière dont on vient de parler vous
vous alliez à 7 sur 7 vous répondiez à
des questions mais je m'en sérieux sur
sur des sujets très graves et très
sérieux donc pour changer un peu je vous
ai fait une interview nulle
[Musique]
vous avez bougé pendant le jingle
c'est la première question non non c'est
une constatation vous avez bougé pendant
le jingle Patrick Bruel
je dois pas bouger non il faut pas
bouger ni prendre mon verre donc on
refait je vais vous faire une interview
nul mais j'ai compris ça
[Musique]
en plus non seulement vous êtes très
séduisant mais vous avez un pouvoir
comique incroyable mais ça fait partie
alors ça fait partie oui de votre
séduction c'est énorme attendez je bouge
plus j'ai le droit de prendre le verre
alors première question interview nul
donc est-ce que vous préférez passer une
préfériez passer une nuit avec Anne
Sinclair avec l'or Sinclair ou avec Bob
Sinclair
c'est pas nul c'est pas nul du tout une
nuit
est-ce que vous préférez Hitler ou
Staline pourquoi parce qu'il a tué plus
de gens vous n'avez pas demandé pourquoi
il est nul votre interview
répondre entre la peste et le cholérac
j'ai pas le droit de dire ni l'un ni
l'autre ah non non moi j'aime bien les
gens qui disent quand les gens répondent
je trouve ça nul voilà je peux pas vous
vous dites une réponse ok entre les deux
voilà très bien est-ce que vous préférez
Pompidou Giscard
ça c'est dur bah c'est un peu de gens
qui arrivent à répondre moi moi j'ai une
sympathie pour la bonne humide Pompidou
donc a priori je dirais plutôt Pompidou
plutôt Pompidou alors maintenant c'est
la question la question Clotilde de
Kourou c'est le type de courroie a
inventé une question vous le connaissez
que le titre j'ai tourné un film avec
elle elle est adorable alors est-ce que
vous seriez prêt à embrasser 100 fois
une paire de chaussettes sales par amour
non non elle oui
vous voulez la question Pierre Bellemare
allez-y la question
Pierre Bellemare c'est comment
vendreiez-vous un vibromasseur qui se
branche sur la lune cigare
comment vendre
vibromasseur là c'est pas cette chanson
là qui se branche sur l'allume-cigare
comment je le vendrai c'est-à-dire qu'au
quel argument vous vous développeriez
pour le vendre mais c'est très pratique
[Rires]
alors imaginez
à la télé dans sa bagnole en disant
c'est très pratique
imaginez quand vous greffe un cerveau
si vous préférez avoir le cerveau de
Étienne Daho de Julien Courbet ou de
ticket olgado
Étienne Daho Étienne Daho
[Applaudissements]
Étienne Daho Julien Courbet aussi
de circonstances atténuantes un vieux
qui se tape des jeunes ou un jeune qui
tape sur des vieux
c'est difficile une bonne question ça
c'est une bonne question
consentants oui c'est vrai ou
consentante alors que les gens sur qui
on tape en général sont pas
fondamentalement consentants votre
punition préférée je dis ça pour nos
amis est-ce que c'est d'être pincé
mordus piqué ou griffer pince non mort
non
aiguille ou griffé
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu